jennipher Reardon's family and friends
described her as passionate in giving
the New Mexico mother of two was a vice
president at Wells Fargo and supporter
of Albuquerque Charities her
sister-in-law says Jennifer lived a
remarkable life she was a wonderful
mother full of energy full of creativity
full of giving caring love she and
Michael were one in the same just a
beautiful beautiful family together
beautiful couple
she was just involved in everything in a
huge way just always giving and
fundraising and helping she was just a
beautiful person from the inside out and
you know that's that's just wonderful
gift just it just an angel I think and
now hopefully she's somebody's guardian
angel Riordan is the first passenger on
a u.s. airline to die in an accident
since 2009 those family pictures of the
ridden family are so tough to see
because all of us who fly anybody flies
that's the last thing you think can
happen to you sitting by a window and
then to hear she had her seatbelt on
makes it even more terrifying to me it's
become so routine yeah that just a shock
in the middle of why my heart goes out
to them and then I keep thinking about
Tammy Jo the pilot right the pilot who
really did a miraculous job god forbid
any of us are in a situation like that
but we can rest assured that these
pilots are the best pilots in the world
that's our US carrier so you know the
reminder of that you hear it in that
talk with the tower yes how come and
like she's just ordering takeout that
she was on the controls